hi everyone alex jen here hope you're
all keeping well
currently in the uk we're in lockdown
and with it being winter the weather's
pretty miserable outside the days are
short
so there's not really that much
opportunity to train outside inside
we're often confined by space and we
don't really have that room to train
particularly with weapons today i'm
going to go through some stuff with the
bakken and maybe give you some ideas to
think about
when training and how that actually
limited space
can sometimes help your technique
okay to start with let's have a look at
what space i've got around me i've got
wall behind me
there's a radiator down here the shield
hanging up on the wall
i've got a chair which is probably out
of shot and the table
so it's only given me a small space a
width about that much
and there's a cabinet over there
and then there's a door over on this
side
so it's not really much room
particularly
width wise lengthwise i've got a little
bit
of room maybe a couple of couple of
meters
above me it's a normal ceiling height
so if i was to get my ken
there we go i'm touching the ceiling
there at that sort of height
i can just if i stand my top toes reach
it
so for most people this
puts them off because they think well
obviously the ceiling is quite low
and the tendency might be well if i
start to raise
the ken feels like well okay at this
point
i'm going to be hitting the ceiling so
it's it seems like it's too low
if you watch me here i'll keep my arms
extended
and if you notice the ken isn't hitting
the ceiling
but yeah i'm still able to raise it
behind my head with my arm extended
there
and draw it back down without collapsing
my arms into some funny position
so how do i do that so if any of you see
my previous video i talk about
weightlessness
i'll link it either above or in the
description down below
and i say when we're lifting the
anything
when you're lifting from underneath here
it's easier and lighter than if you're
holding it
out here and raising at this point when
i push forward i'm using my hips to
connect
there so it's acting as a lever when my
hips are square
at this point the rotation point is now
around my shoulder
but the sword is perpendicular to my
uh arm and i keep it that way um
i don't raise just straight up like this
when i've got it here i'm actually still
pushing out
from this side and as i take it around
i'm it's like i'm reaching for the end
of the
the hilt and at this point here that's
where it's really extended
like i'm trying to grab up towards it
and then i pull it back down
for the cut so the motion of the
the ken isn't going just upwards like
this or raising it
that's what you're not meant to do
raising in an arc like this
is basically pushing up and then it's
continuing to push up here
as it raises up like that that's the
motion
then when it reverses it's actually
coming forward
and then down rather than just looping
over the top if i was cutting in an arc
where my arms are just
coming down like this all the weight is
going to be at this
end which is then going to drive my
shoulders up
whereas when i push it forwards i can
still keep that posture
without compromising the cut so that was
the first bury but what else could i do
well there's a wall here so i can't
really take it round for the fifth
sabori
and this side there is space so i could
always take it round
raise and cut
i could do the same again but this time
we footwork so i'll change
and i'll have my left foot forward and
i'll take it around
so i load up then i can step and cut
again load up
step and cut i could do it obviously on
the
opposite side now the space is on my
right side
i bring it up and cut so this is just
with the
left foot forward now and just shifting
forward
could also obviously do it with the step
so
this time i'll change my feet around so
raise up step and cut
so we could also look at the first two
cuts of hapagiri
so it starts like the first suburi where
we're raising up
and coin then we turn and cut the
opposite way
and again we can just continue that
movement going from side to side the way
that this works
is by keeping the point online and again
the space helps it stops us
drifting off to the side and doing
something like this because otherwise
we'd hit the wall
we want to try and keep that point in
line
with my body if you like we turn turn
turn
until it's raised right above my head
here i want my arms extended like i
mentioned before
and then we cut down so the the sword
doesn't really leave
this cent central line so as long as
you've got that space
you see i don't actually need that much
space either side
i can just turn
cut turn cut
you can also put a thrust into this
depending on how much space you have
depends on whether you'll be able to
pull the thrust in if you've got a
little bit more space you might be able
to
step through with the thrust a bit like
on the seventh sabori
so when you have these movements you can
look at blending them together
see what you can fit in with the limited
space that you've got
all of these restrictions actually help
you to refine your technique
and with all these movements there's no
rush if you just
take it slow try link them all together
try and feel what sort of space you have
and what's available
within the range of where you are
take it easy when you're practicing i
don't want you breaking anything in your
house
these are just some ideas for you to
possibly play with
and to think about which hopefully might
help your technique
i hope you found that interesting i'd
like to hear your thoughts in the
comments down below
is this something that you practice or
is it something that you can maybe
incorporate into your practice
next time i'm going to be looking at the
joe we're going to continue
with this idea of training indoors and
what we can possibly do with the weapons
in a confined
space remember to like share and
subscribe as this really helps the
channel grow
until next time take care and i will see
you soon
you